this Reddit user made the longest
Starfield ship I have ever seen I am not
going to make any dick jugs really want
to though but a very interesting thing
about this outside of its absurd size
like I wonder what it's like to walk
through is that it also for some reason
turns extremely fast look at that that
turning speed is nuts and I'm pretty
sure that the people at the far end who
are moving that quickly are dying like
I'm pretty sure there's so much GeForce
up there that they're just getting
smashed against the walls I I genuinely
don't think that you can live through
this clearly it's the strongest material
known to man that it doesn't Bend when
turning anyway but for any people who
are up the front of that ooh I think
you're in for a real bad time